[Música]
con nuestro segundo invitado al día
hablamos del más reciente informe del
programa de Naciones Unidas para el
medio ambiente que reveló las
consecuencias del actual aumento de la
explotación del gas natural en América
Latina y el Caribe el informe subraya
que el concepto de gas natural como
transición o combustible verde ese
cuestionable y en el peor de los casos
engañoso sale vamos a Gustavo mañas él
es el director adjunto para América
Latina y el Caribe del programa la ONU
para medio ambiente Gracias Gustavo por
estar con nosotros nuevamente en directo
América de Francia 24 es el gas natural
una buena inversión para América Latina
y el Caribe realmente
Hola Muy buenos días
Pues la verdad es que creemos que no
creemos que no es una buena opción para
promover la transición energética para
reducir las facturas de los ciudadanos y
tampoco lo es para crear más empleos en
la región que es lo que nos hace falta
para salir del actual crisis
Gustavo porque nos seguimos enfocando en
combustibles fósiles también como lo es
el gas natural que recordemos que en
natural estaría abajo de la tierra en su
estado natural pero no cuando lo
extraemos no cuando lo quemamos para
para generar pues la energía que
necesitamos nosotros Entonces por qué
nos seguimos enfocando en eso y no más
bien ya hacer nuestra transición a las
energías renovables es más rentable
Incluso en energías renovar renovables
llamadas también verdes o limpias que la
que estamos haciendo en este momento de
hidrocarburos
pues es muy buena pregunta porque no
está pasando esto o porque no está
pasando esto a la velocidad que debería
estar pasando y seguimos dependiendo de
un combustible fósil que nos crea más
cambio climático y nos crea Pues esa
situación de debilidad de vulnerabilidad
que tienen nuestras economías no tanto
en la agricultura como en las
infraestructuras como desafortunadamente
con las pérdidas humanas que estamos
viendo con Los huracanes en la región
Mira yo creo que ha habido una
dependencia de muchas empresas de muchos
gobiernos a un sector
energético específico el de los fósiles
y yo creo que tanto los gobiernos como
las empresas deben de salir de esa caja
no donde se han metido sus sectores el
de la energía y no solamente el de los
fósiles y existen alternativas mucho más
competitivas económicamente en nuestro
estudio hemos demostrado que habrían
tres veces más beneficios económicos
netos en una disminución de costos de
capital pero también de costos
operativos de impulsar las energías
renovables que Comparado con el gas
natural básicamente a 2050 tendríamos un
escenario de crecimiento de empleos con
el gas natural de más de 35.000 empleos
de los que existen a día de hoy o en un
escenario digamos tendencial En
comparación con más de tres millones de
empleos que se podrían generar con la
renovables no y de la misma manera que
vemos esa dependencia y es altísima
vulnerabilidad por ejemplo en Europa no
que ha creado esta guerra con
de Rusia con Ucrania no con estos
altísimos precios del gas y se ha
demostrado que digamos esa dependencia
del gas ruso pues les está creando
vulnerabilidad porque seguimos
afianzando esa dependencia hacia un
combustible que además de ser finito
tiene alternativas mucho más costo
efectivas beneficiosas económicamente
Esa es la gran pregunta y ese es el
liderazgo que necesitamos en esta región
no salirnos de este marco en el que nos
hemos metido nosotros mismos Gustavo
también le quiero preguntar cuánto se
tardaría en cambiar también digamos la
infraestructura de consumo de las
energías que utilizamos en actualidad
digamos cuánto nos tardaría Cambiar toda
unas energías verdes y limpias y también
hablando de porcentaje le quiero
preguntar cuánto estaríamos reduciendo
no en nivel de gases de efecto
invernadero hacia el planeta Así que si
hacemos esta transición
Muchas gracias muy buenas preguntas Mira
la transición lo que nos dice la agencia
Internacional de la energía Es que para
tener un 50% de posibilidades de
mantenernos en un clima digamos seguro
no superando los 1,5 grados debemos de
parar a día de hoy nuevas inversiones En
exploración y explotación de
combustibles fósiles y esto incluye
también el gas natural Entonces tenemos
básicamente hasta el año
2050 para hacer una transición completa
y tener una economía completamente
descarbonizada Entonces esta esta
transición pues va a ser distinta
dependiendo del país pero nosotros ya
partimos en América Latina y el Caribe
de una muy buena base que es que
prácticamente cerca del entre el 50 y el
60% de la generación eléctrica en
nuestra región
las energías renovables Entonces nos va
a costar mucho menos hacer esa
transición principalmente estoy hablando
de la generación hidroeléctrica Entonces
yo creo que esa transición en nuestra
región puede ser altamente beneficiosa y
mucho más rápida que en otras partes del
mundo claro Gustavo también ahorita ya
está creo que el domingo si no si no me
equivoco comienza la cop 27 en Egipto en
materia de acuerdo realmente vinculantes
para los países qué podemos esperar no
que no se quede una Cumbre más en el
papel y no sé si podemos hacer una un
balance digamos no de lo que fue la cop
26 a la con 27 y que se ha logrado
realmente implementar
pues la cop 27 Debería ser una Cup de la
implementación todos los aspectos
relativos a la negociación del acuerdo
de París que han sido cerrados digamos
que no hay no hay brechas adicionales
que definir se trata ahora de hablar de
cómo vamos a cumplir ese objetivo de
reducción de las emisiones alineado con
esos objetivos del acuerdo de París de
1,5 o de dos grados por la banda ancha
digamos no entonces una Cup exitosa
sería aquella en que los jefes de estado
y los ministros de los países viniesen
con nuevos compromisos
adicionales a los que ya tiene que nos
pongan en esa en ese Rango de 1,5 5
grados y para eso hay que dejar de
explotar nuevos yacimientos de gas
natural pero también de petróleo y de
carbono